[Música]
o andamento aqui o jorge que foi o show
começou com vida que hoje eu sou mais
importante porque eu controlo o tempo o
tempo futuro portanto é uma pessoa com
uma função vital hoje aqui é de também
lançar um pouco de conforto porque
aceitei pela primeira vez de vir falar
sobre um tema sobre o qual nada sair
novas conhecer vocês nem conhecia o
futuro nos o bruxo é no mês como estamos
todos vivos
uma das coisas que eu sei é que o futuro
não é um estímulo
não é uma coisa do futuro é uma viagem e
nessa viagem pelo fato de estarmos todos
vivos
estamos todos nessa viagem já começarmos
a pouco eu senti um pouco já velho
porque já trabalhava em comunicação
marketing quando vocês nasceram na
verdade é que todos nós temos um
percurso meu percurso
minha vida minha viagem começou há 46
anos e vamos contar um pouco desses
episódios que marcaram a minha história
e concluam neste momento que se há 46
anos na aldeia aqui tudo isto diesel
concelho de santa comba dão foi neste
momento rústico é esse
quando eu menos uso foram aos postos
todos foram os três rés no meu caso como
esse todo mundo então foguetes
todo mundo é o fogo de artifício e uma
experiência que se repete todos os anos
sempre que eu faço anos há
fogo-de-artifício 30 anos eu acreditei
que é por causa de mim até descobrir que
não era só a passagem de ano em que
estava ser chá da vovó um tema cheguei
lá os meus filhos mais pequenos ainda
acreditam que por causa de mim mas o
facto fazer amizade e 31 dezembro acaba
por ser um facto que me marcou muito
a viragem de página é o dia em que nós
encerramos um ciclo e queremos iniciar
um outro complementa o momento meramente
simbólico mas é um momento marcante
quando che o pai estava fazendo estava
emigrado na alemanha e eu tenho um
nascimento rústica em casa dos meus avós
al ani maio a minha mãe me ligou também
para o menino foi ter com o meu pai e eu
fiquei com os meus avós e aos dois anos
e meio eu fiz a minha primeira viagem de
avião sozinho é interessam à colônia na
alemanha onde fui com os meus pais
chegaram à colônia não fazia a menor
idéia que nos pais não acontece nem meu
pai nem conhecia minha mãe e a questão
que se coloca é como é que isso nos
marca como é que isto marca nossa
existência como é que essas experiências
marcam aquilo que nós vamos ser como
elas marcam o nosso estudo chega amanhã
com 20 de maio já tinha começado a falar
de um país ainda inclui aprender a
língua uma creche tem que aprender a
falar ou não a minha experiência de vida
muito desde muito cedo foi marcada por
uma mudança em mudanças radicais
fiz todo o meu percurso ciclável amanhã
aos 9 anos sou atropelado por um
automóvel passo cerca de três meses
acamado e com novos e já não está em que
reaprender a caminhar
o corpo tinha se esquecido caminhada
vamos dizer assim aprendemos na
bicicleta sabemos nada secreta para
sempre as coisas tão básicas como
caminhar o corpo esqueceu se a
musculatura entre o seu encaminhamento
do corpo o corpo teve novamente aprender
a caminhar aos 15 anos
os meus pais e eu na altura já convoca
matéria decidimos optar por portugal 10º
ano
mandam fazer o meu ensino secundário e
novamente mudança radical porque
subitamente estava na minha pátria a
falar ou ter que falar uma língua que
não dominava era português e disse que
queria aprender o português como língua
dominante como
a língua materna que na altura não era
minha já na altura era ou não equipara
queda agência de camarão e fui chamado
ou não na menina nunca te preciso
discriminado nunca tinha se diferenciar
até pessoa um tempo alto camuflado na
paisagem e aqui pra ser ou não tive que
me adaptar e foi muito difícil fazer o
ensino secundário
hoje quando pega nos meus primeiros
testes escritos em português nesta
semana três morreram rir porque o
próprio não percebi que queria mas foi
capaz e fiz meu o teste um ano das
primeiras um efeito o 12º ano é que são
os colocou foi o que vou fazer a seguir
quis ser padre mas tive medo do sistema
pois pensa ser polícia mas não via
concursos abertos koff patrol copa como
voluntário não quiseram colocar na
reserva e portanto foi concluído o
ensino superior tem o curso de direito
em coimbra foi minha única candidatura
não entrar ele uma décima
e passei um ano a trabalhar nos
supermercados meus pais em santa comba
dão no ano seguinte
teimoso vou me candidatar só direito em
coimbra tendo entrado com a mesma média
do último colocado nessa altura depois
candidatem a comunicação social quer um
curso que até então não tinha passado
pela cabeça mas gostava de jornalismo
estava escrever gostava de contar
histórias gostava de revelar a verdade e
fui para lisboa ou não vencia em
comunicação social jornalismo como todos
os alunos que acabam o curso de
jornalismo área do jornalismo
há sempre a doença que você é um
jornalista durante alguns meses
a idéia é experimentar brincar como
costumo dizer aos jornalistas
primeiro como estagiário na agência lusa
e depois como
estagiário no cenário econômico foram
experiências muito boas
fiz algumas manchetes esteve alguns
furos mas ao fim de alguns meses de
trabalhar como estagiário
cheguei à conclusão que não era aquilo
que eu queria por um lado porque vão mal
isso é que o que me propuseram um
convencimento não correspondia àquilo
que eram as minhas expectativas e pronto
ao prontuário tive contacto com várias
experiências de influência política e
econômica
daquilo que era a política editorial dos
órgãos de comunicação coisa que o
fundamento e teve que era aquilo que eu
queria voltar para a faculdade estudar
mais um carrinho e pouco tempo depois
que comecei a trabalhar na área da
comunicação empresarial
podemos dizer que é um lado negro um
lado branco da comunicação ao lado bom
mas mal e no fundo o mar tem muitas
vezes é vista como normal da comunicação
o deputado a nossa área que foi que eu
fui cair e aí que eu tenho trabalhado
facto dos últimos 20 anos
trabalhei durante cinco anos na
sociedade ponto verde uma organização
promove a reciclagem tem mais uma
mudança o nível da produção de
comportamento e em 2004 fazendo aqui oea
constitui a minha empresa própria na
área da comunicação em 2006
decidimos eu ea minha mulher concretizar
um sonho de infância em um sonho
partilhado que era
vamos viver colocando vamos criar uma
família no campo ter k vao uma quinta
essas coisas todas
e se viu nos mudarmos novamente para
santa comunhão em 2006 pregamos na
altura já os dois filhos que tínhamos e
na empresa e mudarmos para santa comba
dão onde constituímos a segunda empresa
em 2006 que foi em 2007 na terceira
empresa ea partir daí que nós neste
momento trabalhamos tanto eu estou onde
estou
pode acontecer uma série de decisões ao
longo deste percurso ao longo desta
viagem são decisões às vezes violentas
de vingança mas que são decisões que nos
marcam e que marcam aquilo que vão ser
as opções que for nós vamos ter no
futuro tudo que o futuro não é algo que
acontece
o futuro é algo que nós construímos
portanto se nós achamos que podemos
estar sentados à espera que no futuro
venha ter connosco e certamente que não
vai acontecer
o futuro é o resultado daquilo que nós
vamos fazendo
claro que nem todas as decisões são
nossas
nem todas as decisões são individuais
são influenciadas por contextos são
influenciadas pelas famílias nós
conhecemos são influenciados pelos
cursos pela formação que nós tiramos
geral que vai fazendo é um percurso
todos os dias nós vamos fazendo todos os
dias nós vamos construindo a questão que
se coloca é que nos foi aqui colocada
por dia e hoje é o vosso tudo
estatisticamente
você certamente tem mais futuro à frente
do que eu sou mais velho mas ele também
tem futuro amanhã o meu futuro todos os
dias esses estudos que colocam o
presente que nós vivemos hoje
dá-nos a matéria prima com a qual nós
vamos construir nosso futuro o futuro e
isso depende de cada um
o presente para construir jogos a quem
aproveito o presente os mesmos recursos
para fazer colorir tosca ou olaria mais
elaborada
qual é o vosso presente é uma decisão
vossa é uma decisão que não é nem
inevitável nem linear nem é em química
costuro nós queremos que seja bom e
queremos que eu seja positivo para nós
mas o futuro nos prometem seriamente
sucesso
os futuros profissionais são opções
e essas opções cavar a nós escolher elas
e portanto é questão que se coloca não é
ficar sentado à espera do futuro é
construiu imprudentemente da confiança
que nós possamos ter nos sucessos ou
fracassos que devemos enfrentar esses
mesmos vamos ter que ir às aulas
não há sucesso em fracasso e nós não
conseguimos saborear o sucesso também se
soubermos o que é o fracasso na minha
vida pessoal e profissional está marcado
por mudanças mudanças que não fui eu que
escolhi muitas delas outras em face das
lutas já fui eu que escolhi e hoje não
posso dizer que seja uma pessoa de
sucesso timbaú sucesso espero vir ter
mais este também fracasso quer
pessoalmente quer profissionalmente
cabos é vocês trilharam esse caminho
fazerem essa viagem para que o vosso
futuro se concretiza com a ajuda dos que
já cá estão nos que já estão na viagem
há mais tempo conosco podem ajudar vos a
fazer essa viagem é sobretudo pelo vosso
próprio caminho
não tenho medo de iniciar essa viagem
o que vos posso dizer olhando para
aquilo que são as perspectivas do futuro
das previsões daquilo que esperam por um
algo que eu constato é que as mudanças
são no só uma constante mas acontece em
uma velocidade cada vez maior em todas
as áreas profissionais e pessoais
hoje além de trabalhar na área do
martin do marketing digital do aulas
marketing digital
eu como licenciada e não existia
internet
eu tive o meu primeiro computador já na
faculdade o que hoje então o nível do
digital acontece com os equipamentos
móveis com inteligência artificial etc
somos danças que eram inimagináveis
do ponto de vista da previsão do futuro
real há meia dúzia de anos atrás não
eram inimagináveis do ponto de vista de
ficção científica
nós olhamos pra filmes produzidos há 20
30 40 anos atrás
já temos muitos dos funcionários que
hoje estamos a viver
existe ponto de vista de imaginação
humana e imaginação mar é uma coisa
terrível mas maravilhosa ao mesmo tempo
permite nos construir cenários depois
quando vista real se concretizam
agora no início do ano 2019 foi acordado
um filme que é o brasil entrou na via
para 2019 precisamente situações em que
havia entre ação entre humanos e robôs
inteligentes artificial os sistemas
biônicos filme criado nos anos 80
e essa realidade hoje está muito
presente com uma realidade provável
já a seguir a questão que se coloca é a
seguinte qual vai ser o vosso futuro
caminho já que vocês vão escolher e que
tipo de pessoa que vocês querem ser
eu da minha parte o que vos posso dizer
é que profissionalmente
podemos ser o que queremos e podemos
escolher caminhos diferentes
eu trabalho há 20 anos nesta área não
sei se vou acabar aqui não sei que não
vou ter que fazer uma reciclagem
profissional daqui a alguns anos eu fico
escutado um caso fica esgotado as coisas
mudam e tenho que estar disponível para
essa mudança tem que estar disponível
para me adaptar e
novos desafios o mais importante no
entanto e é com isso que eu quero também
passados e independentemente do futuro
que vocês venham escolher sejam bons
sejam bons profissionalmente sejam bons
naquilo que venham a fazer mas sobretudo
sejam bons de bom dado o valor da
bondade é um valor determinante para que
o que vocês venham a ser no futuro e é
um valor determinante pra que eu costuro
nos podem levar pra vocês é bom dava uns
com os outros ao mandado com o mundo é
abordado com o tio cruzei a peça boom
dado que nos vai fazer valorizar a vida
que é o tempo que passa aos poucos está
quase acabada é o tempo que vocês pois
vamos valorizar podemos ficar sentados e
às vezes a viagem tem pausas nós numa
viagem em cima e estamos a andar às
vezes paramos e ficamos apreciar a
paisagem mas o tempo não pára e portanto
aproveitem o tempo
xd de cárter dia faça o melhor desse
tema sobretudo sejam bons sejam bons
projetos sejam bons para a vida e sejam
bons pronto tá em uma boa tarde
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]